hi there steve kaufman here
i want to continue talking about this
importance of being relaxed when we're
learning languages
i think
one of the biggest obstacles to
successful language learning
is stage fright
people think they're performing
when they're speaking a foreign language
we're not performing we're just
communicating
and as long as we're focused on
communicating
we will succeed
and communication
takes place when we're listening when
we're reading when we're speaking when
we're writing
these are all forms of communicating in
in another language and if our focus is
firmly on communicating we will
expose our brains to enough of the
language that we will continue to
improve
i constantly get
letters emails from people to my blog
for example at the linguistic language
or at link
people say you know i've been studying
english or some other language for
so much time and i don't think i'm
making any progress and what should i do
and stuff
and my answer always is just enjoy
the language you will continue to
improve
some people are going to do better some
people are going to have an easier time
pronouncing the language
some people have learned more languages
and therefore might do better
but as long as you're enjoying the
language that's fine mission
accomplished and if you spend the time
with the language
you will improve
and uh
you know there was a discussion uh on
one of our forums at link
someone raised the issue of
of pitch in japanese in fact they were
concerned about uh this person was
concerned about the accents
of some of the content at link whether
it was from osaka or tokyo and
my contention is with all these issues
of accent whether it be in spanish or
portuguese or french or english
it really doesn't matter
uh you'll gradually imitate the form of
the language that you either hear the
most or that you want to
uh imitate but you should in fact expose
yourself to a lot of different accents
it's not going to hurt you
and uh this person felt though that that
was very important to get the pitch
right in japanese and i had never heard
of pitch in japanese i didn't i don't
know what it is
and
this person directed me to some websites
where i saw some tremendously
complicated explanations about pitch
and referring to i think the term was
mora or something which was some other
term other than phoneme it all has to do
with sounds and
and i just think that if
in learning japanese i had to worry
about the pitch
of different words and worry about
whether the person i was speaking to was
using the pitch that i wanted to
imitate i mean it just introduces
another element of complication it's
just like golf the more
uh instruction you have about how to
hold your wrist your knee your shoulder
the less well you can play golf if you
go out there to enjoy the game you're
actually going to do better and you have
to gradually start to feel the swing in
golf and some people in the long run
will do better and some will do less
well
i think in languages the differences are
not as great because in golf you have to
be a very talented
athlete and practice a lot
whereas in language learning we are all
capable of speaking languages but i
think this whole idea of
i mean i learned japanese i never
worried about pitch didn't know it
existed
i don't think i learned one single
grammatical term
in learning japanese i just know that
they say
whatever
whatever it might be
uh and and in speaking japanese
undoubtedly i was always influenced by
the people that i was around so that if
i spent
uh three weeks in the kansai with some
customers down there i might uh come
back speaking with much with more of a
kansai accent and then if i was back in
tokyo then i would lose that it didn't
really matter but i just think if we get
back this idea of stage fright
being such a major inhibiting factor in
language learning the more things we
have to think about
is this the right pitch or in my russian
is this the right case i mean i just let
it come out it'll come out wrong right
and gradually over time it'll come out
right more often and of course i review
the cases in russian but the fewer and
you have to because eventually i want to
speak russian correctly but the fewer
things like that that we introduced
the better the more confident the person
can be that if i have to worry about
pitch it's the same with tones in
chinese
sure when we learn the words we want to
see what tone they are but mostly we
want to get the hang of the rhythm by
listening
and imitating and if i have to think
about the tone of every word in chinese
as i speak then i can't speak
so i guess i just you know it's a bit
like i mentioned in my previous podcast
about this term parasegmentals applied
to learning english the fewer technical
terms we use the fewer technical aspects
of the language that we direct the
learner to try to learn
uh the better
the the fewer inhibitions the learner is
going to have they won't be checking it
for pitch and checking it for tone and
checking it for case and checking it for
this rule and that rule with all the
exceptions
they'll just learn and if they focus on
the meaning focus on communication again
it was the same when i started with
russian
uh the conflict the explanations are
incredibly complicated
i don't say that i don't occasionally
review russian grammar i do
but i don't do it with the intent
of learning it remembering it
i just use the occasional grammar of you
as a reminder and the more i'm exposed
to russian the more natural some of this
stuff starts to become and the more
naturally i'm able to reproduce it when
i speak
so i just because i had these one i had
the one person who emailed me and said
you know i've been learning english for
so long and i still don't feel that i'm
fluent and then this other person
worrying about pitch and this other
person in fact said that that he
considered himself
uh intermediate to advanced like
intermediate two to advanced and he said
he speaks japanese well enough only well
enough to talk to his friends
well if you are intermediate
and you can only talk to your friends
then i think you have a severe
case of stage fright
uh i am quite happy to talk to anyone at
any stage of my
language development because my only
goal is to communicate and if i have
something to communicate i will
communicate even if i'm a ranked
beginner i don't spend a lot of time
talking as a beginner because i don't
have a lot to say i'm not able to say
very much but if the situation is there
if i have to communicate i communicate
with anyone not just with my friends
so there you have it on
pitch
stage fright and just staying relaxed
and natural and focusing on
communicating and being happy with
whatever level we have in the language
at every stage i'm happy
even at the beginning i'm happy i'm
doing a few things in the new language
and as i get better i'll continue to be
happy because i'm communicating
and and every so often i'll experience
certain breakthroughs i read a whole
book and i knew
most of the words
or whatever some sense of confirmation
that we are progressing
but as long as we focus on
communicating and enjoying the language
we will progress so don't be too uptight
out there don't worry about your pitch
bye for now